[Musique]
halloween ce sera dans une semaine on
vient de le voir il ya beaucoup
d'animations prévues bonsoir mélanie et
y en a quelques-unes qu'on peut encore
mentionner un peu envie de frissonner en
famille halloween vous attend à voisins
le bretonneux la ville vous propose
trois films à regarder en famille ils
sont projetés le samedi 26 octobre à
partir de 16 heures c'est à la salle de
la tour sur les images vous aurez sans
doute reconnu la famille adams et 60 au
nous encore le troisième volet d' hôtel
transylvania l'entrée est gratuite mon
ami me déplace autre ambiance
ce que le cinéma au château de dampierre
et oui là c'est les citrouilles qui sont
de sortie alors c'est pas halloween
parce que les équipes ont surtout
souhaité un réchauffé l'atmosphère
parfois brumeuse de ses vacances en
journée on peut se balader en calèche
dans le parc sous des plaids bien chaud
ou s'amuse à faire des photos dans un
carrosse en citrouille à la tombée de la
nuit
l'édifice se dévoile autrement vous avez
des cerceaux lumineux dans la cour du
château vous avez des bulles lumineuse
sur l'étang a eu tant de 7 hectares avec
six grosses bulles qui viennent prendre
la lumière artificielle certes mais en
tout cas voilà qui met l'accent sur ce
patrimoine et puis tout au fond sur le
pavillon sur l'île eh bien nous avons
créé une ambiance fantastique avec une
lumière orange qui sort de ce pavillon
et qui intrigue tout le monde est là une
belle citrouille pourra terminer
séquence consacrée à halloween qui nous
viennent des fermes de gally si vous
venez nous rejoindre il n'ya pas
qu'halloween dans les prochains jours
aussi et non là du côté de château du
château de breteuil on va fêter plutôt
l'histoire de france c'est de manière un
peu original ce qu'il ya des playmobil
alors l'orangerie du château va abriter
plusieurs saynètes de cette histoire
française
l'exposition ceux visés soit horaires
d'ouverture du château et au tarif du
billet d'entrée habituel
ils sont la collection personnelle d'un
grand collectionneur qui s'appelle
dominique béthune et qui collectionne
tous ces petits personnages depuis plus
de onze ans et il en un nombre assez
impressionnant et il faut reconstituer
toutes sortes de deux scènes de thèmes
pour parler des grands les grandes
époques de notre histoire je peux vous
dire qu'il y aura jeanne d'arc et la
révolution française
mais y en a beaucoup d'autres et
justement toutes ces autres histoires
saynètes à découvrir
sont de 26 et 27 octobre merci mélanie
on vous retrouve dans quelques instants
juste après le journal de la rédaction
pour un nouveau 7,8 loisirs et un
programme complet sur les rendez-vous
des prochains jours sur le secteur dans
le département des yvelines